three four and so on and and I'm going
to be firm and say that if you're not
going to be talking specifically about
the Amendments or objections or whatever
then I will stop you I'm not going to
have anything else rattling on it okay
I'm putting it as frankly as that thank
you
I'll tune in recommend too so is there
any prepositions or conservations or
discussions or comments that wish to be
made
okay
so we're checking to the vote
oh true
well R2 now the community expression of
Interest process is formally concluded
with neither preferred part with neither
preferred partner being awarded a
contract
all those in favor
or Canada
okay
okay now I guess
oh that's against
any of sanctions
one
talk to Chairman I've just been advised
by a couple of residents the live stream
has uh crashed so I don't know if you
want to look for that as well so that
people who are trying to actually listen
to this meeting thank you very much I've
just had it come through thank you
well the result of that is 424 against
11 an abstention one so that is carried
when they're going to R3 their officers
conduct a commercial soft Market testing
exercise for the operation of the cafe
at the Mill arts and Event Center
can I ask for an amendment for a date
for this market research to be concluded
by please
[Music]
chairman if I could just provide some
advice the amendment as expressed is not
valid because it's not specific so you
would need to State the dates
rather than just saying could we include
a date by which it would be ended thank
you chair
[Music]
um in consultation with my colleagues
who are suggesting a three-month period
um so Chad for clarity for members the
amended motion would read that officers
conduct a commercial soft Market testing
exercise for the operation of the cafe
at the Mill arts and Event Center
to be completed within a three-month
period
Mrs Wilson
thank you chair incense
in consultation with Phoebe I would
consider amending that down to eight
weeks please I'm on a point of order
please the motion hasn't been seconded
so we can't talk to it apologies
it's been checking that you now care
message thank you thank you councilor hi
and Phoebe is that going to be possible
within eight weeks
I would recommend that you keep with the
three months in order to make it
meaningful just because of resources
internally and holidays I'd say if we
want the men to keep three months that's
accepted and thank you for your advice
sorry and I just confirmed that the
three months is unachievable rather than
the eight weeks and I would recommend
that we would stick with for three
months if we interpret retail purposes
holidays of staff and that as well to
make it a meaningful engagement
thank you and thank you to councilor
Wilson for suggesting the earlier period
a great sentiment
um knowing how difficult it was to go
out in the first instance and get
interest I think that's why we'd all
probably like to see a date on it so
that we can guarantee some attention is
given to it because there's been cries
from the public for quite some time as
we know and we've certainly felt them to
get the Cafe open so we'd welcome
anything we can do to support that from
from this side of the room as well
Council Hoy yeah I'm just confirm I
won't be supporting the amendment
um I believe that will slow down the
process
well members we have an amendment on the
proposition so we'll take a vote
um all those in favor of the amendment
now against
thank you members all those against
thank you members any abstentions
are you fighting
no I'm I'm against
thank you
members it's 21-4
again four abstentions and eleven
against four against four against 11
Amendment uh
of stations so that is carried thank you
[Music]
members
those recommendations have been
substantial so we now don't need to
re-vote on the amended
R2 as it was R3 sorry so we need to now
vote on on that admit that that
recommendation has amended so right so
we've now amended it so we're now voting
on the form potential board thank you
chairman would you be so kind just to
read out the amended Amendment please
many motion thank you
Sam and I'm happy to to read that out
again so the amended recommendation
three now reads that officers conduct a
commercial soft Market testing exercise
for the operation of the cafe at the
Mill arts and events center to be
completed within a three-month period
thank you chair
members we now have this new motion
we'll take a vote on that thing as
amended all those in favor of that
motion
thank you very much
are those against
man
any abstentions
[Music]
members that's uh 27 4 none against and
nine abstentions thank you that's Carrie
when I take out the R4
the budget of 6500 is allocated to
support the reopening of the bars for
events at the Midwest and send to our
Event Center the bar is to be operated
by a third party
eternity events as the per appendix one
which is accepted
council Mrs Bellman the apologies chair
this is a very minor amendment that I
hope my colleagues would support as it
stands the motion reads that a budget of
six and a half thousand I believe it
should say up to six and a half thousand
because the exempt appendix and I've
checked with officers that I can speak
to this because I'm not talking about
any of the commercial information but
the partner has stated they would
happily contribute and oversee that six
and a half thousand pounds worth of
improvements so I'm not sure why we are
paying the full six and a half thousand
pound
um to a commercial for a commercial
offering when he's already offered to
contribute so I would just like to see
it say up to for the purpose of clarity
and to allow officers to negotiate
accordingly and to get the best possible
deal for the Mill pool and taxpayers
um I would also just like to add because
it's not clear in the report some of the
items that are stated within that six
and a half thousand pound will we be
getting those from third parties at no
cost such as the glasses which typically
you see Brands give to a venue such as
this so just to ensure that we're
getting the absolute best value for
money but to be clear I support the the
motion I would just like to see it say
up to if possible thank you
okay sure Mr Mason
yeah just an observation chairman
um been in finance for quite some time
budget actually infers that this is
variable
the fact that there's an end a figure on
the budget infers it's variable up to
anyway so I'm not going to support that
either because it doesn't go against the
good sense of accountancy and financial
practice
cancer Mrs Wilson did you want to speak
uh hello chair uh yes I did but uh
following on from what uh councilor
Mason has just said uh no I don't thank
you okay
thank you
[Music]
thank you and whilst I don't disagree
with the explanation councilor Mason has
given a very a very clear one what I
would say is this Council on many of
occasion have asked us to change the
wording right across the board of up to
for absolute Clarity because a number of
people have read that that we will be
spent up we will be spending six and a
half thousand pounds when it's not
necessary thank you chairman
um point of order councilor Belton never
had her Amendment seconded
that's a Steptoe
I'm happy to second that
anybody else right shall we
have
they are objecting to this uh
up to but the next report says that a
budget of up to ten thousand pounds is
allocated so I don't see why this one
can't say it's up to as well could we
stick to this motion at the moment
please
I'm just saying it's up to on the next
motion so why can't this one be up to
thank you cash emotion
thank you well Jenna according to the
Constitution without the uh Amendment
um being actually second dude it's like
so that debate was unnecessary and it
has failed
with
well we have a proposition in uh for an
amendment on this particular item so
we're going to put it to the vote so
all those in favor of the amendment of
this um
Financial difference you know the
variable as suggested by cancer Belton
all those in favor
thank you members all those against
thank you
again
any abstentions
well there's 15 4 20 against and one
abstention therefore that has been
declined that's available so we go back
to the original
recommendations in
for um
R4 and that is that the budget of 6500
is allocated to support the reopening of
the bars events at the Milwaukee Art
Convention Center if I'll be be operated
by a third party
eternity events as a peripendix one
which is exempt all those in favor
um can we speak to that motion then
place we spoke to the amendment before
we haven't spoken to this motion
[Music]
unless you have gone in we're listening
to what's being said everybody has a say
thank you
um
the end of that site item says appendix
one which is an exempt item I haven't
had sites of that item I've been on
holiday in Germany we're very limited in
internet access
um I turned up this evening I asked for
the exempt papers which they haven't
been provided to me so I don't even know
what that exempt item is all about so
therefore I'm wondering how we can vote
on it if not maybe not everybody has
read it
it's your problem
some of
chairman I'm happy to provide advices as
monitoring officer on this item the
papers have been published within the
legal deadlines if any member feels that
they haven't accessed that information
and been able to digest that and use
that to inform their decision then they
should abstain in the vote thank you
well that makes it clear so when I take
the vote
um all those in favor of that
recommendation
oh
thank you members those against
any abstentions
three
members we have 33 for none against and
three abstentions that is carried
we're now going to go on to R5 that the
budget of up to up to
ten thousand pounds these other call you
for a structural survey of the mealwarts
and Event Center
cancer Steptoe
thank you chairman
I I do take on board the opening
comments from
a chief exec
uh I am very concerned about the survey
I know that a number of surveys over
many years have been carried out on this
particular building
but
with a view to what's happened recently
and the fact that the government have
changed the goal posts on this are
AAC concrete over the last few days
I don't believe that the surveys that we
have had done in the previous occasions
have necessarily had that in mind
the Gophers have been changed quite
considerably
I know today having been to other
meetings in other places
that there is a lot of concern about
schools hospitals
and Civic buildings
right across the board to the extent I
happen to bump into the Secretary of
State the schools in the car park today
and I noticed particularly worried about
this is an issue
so I am going to propose
that we need to
tighten up
the specification of the survey that is
being talked about here
I feel that it should include a thorough
inspection
particularly for
the rack concrete
and also concrete cancer which is two
different things
also as well the possibility
of asbestos
you have to bear in mind first of all
the chair
please
I'm really very sorry to do this but
this isn't on topic as to what we should
be discussing
thank you
yeah we're discussing the budget up to
ten thousand pounds of structural survey
not not the rack
foreign
[Music]
as I say in particular asbestos
an over experience
but asbestos can be very prevalent in
this particular building bear in mind
when it was actually built which was the
early 70s
I'd also like to see
the structural survey include other
items as well
the heating for example and the
administration is very keen on
environmental standards
and how the environment is very working
I wouldn't mind betting that the heating
system in here
is considerably out of date
oh sorry what I want to hold a chairman
we are talking about structural surveys
sustainability in the building is also
mentioned in the report and that's also
taken care of through other committees
this is about a structural survey
if I can continue chairman
I was going to say as part of the
structural survey
we need to be looking at the way the
heating system is integrated within the
structure
particularly the air conditioning
and see how that works
speak personally I have quite a concern
about stuff that's all over our heads
you in particular chairman how safe is
all of that structurally how safe is all
that equipment that's hanging onto that
roof
you're sitting under a considerable
amount of stuff there
so I would like to see that included
within this instruction the structural
survey
I was going to mention the fact that the
lift hasn't worked for months but okay
can I remind you of the time
have you said that's all of the valve
I believe
the budget of ten thousand pounds will
not be anywhere near sufficient to carry
out those full assessments
and I would like to propose
that's the officers take this away
look at what I've said includes the
items that I've said
and advice on a revised budget
to take this forward and I believe that
should be done within a three-month
period
so that's my proposal Jim
thank you I'll take councilman sir first
I'm taking them in order
I would like to call for a second or on
that first though we don't have any
further confusion thank you you meant to
say that's okay
foreign
thank you chairman
um I'm not clear what the amendment
actually is that councilman Steptoe is
proposing at this moment in time however
what I've heard seems to suggest a
negation to the existing recommendation
which would not be allowed as an
amendment
essentially I think councilor Steptoe
you're proposing that you don't vote or
you defer this item so that officers can
go away and look at a more complete
recommendation around what's contained
in that structural assessment structural
survey and revisit the budget so it's
not an amendment it's potentially a
motion to defer German if I may I'll
take the office of advice on that
particular point and take on board what
what he said and looked for it to
deferred on the basis that I have
already said
thank you
[Music]
I needed a second diversity man thank
you chairman for the sake of avoidance
of any doubt I would like to Second it
and I will await my turn in due course
to come back later in the debate thank
you Jim thank you councilmation
chairman um I seem to be coming back to
process quite quite a lot I suppose
because that's um the life that I have
in in the financial services industry
um surely when we we write in Council
that we're talking about a structural
survey then there are
there are already definitions within the
local government sector as to what a
structural survey actually means and
more particularly around the procurement
of such a survey so I've I find it
unnecessary to
take something back to offices to
specify
a a set of terms and conditions for a
structural survey when indeed those
things are already laid down
I'm content to vote for a structural
survey knowing that our officers have
those rules
and those definitions and those industry
standards to actually fall back on
I don't know why these these amendments
which are almost semantics are coming
forward
consistently
thank you chairman
has already been mentioned by councilor
Mason
the structural survey will be carried
out by government approval of their
recommendations now whether there is
Rack in this building whether there is
asbestos or anything else the survey
will tell us exactly what we need to
know
whether it is sufficient we can only get
the experts to do that it's obvious that
Mr the councilor's Steptoe is an expert
on these structural surveys from what
he's mentioned so let's have him to do
the structural survey thank you
thank you chair I'd remind the council
that
um it wasn't that long ago that we had a
condition survey done so if this uh this
building and included in that was the
heating and recommendations on the
heating so I don't see any point in
going over that again
um as far as the structural survey
itself goes any uh surveyor who is worth
his support will be taking into
consideration anything that is current
that should be looked at and I would
suggest that rack is something that
would be very high on their list to make
sure that they do actually cover that
any structural survey that is done as
well would naturally cover any inclusion
of any uh
suspicion of
um there being an asbestos in the
building one thing that worries me about
the amendment that has been put forward
is that it's going to delay the
procedure yet again so if that is the
case could I suggest that if this motion
is taken up that we actually put a an
additional Amendment to the amendment
that that once the
um
the cost of the survey has been
confirmed that it be ratified
and approved by the chairman and by the
leader of the council to avoid any
future delays thank you
um Tara I can answer that one with a
reasonably straightforward answer no you
can't make that Amendment because the
motion is to defer so you can't amend a
motion to defer with additional
information
[Music]
is because the sentence is up to ten
thousand pounds and I
in my opinion I can't see where ten
thousand pound would go in a structural
survey on particularly
um concerned about the roof because
there might be things we want to put on
top of it for somebody mentioned
sustainability and once you start if you
have to start working on that even
you're looking at touching the fabric of
the building so it'd be like to know
it's actually in the fabric the building
connecting to the roof so I'll do
something ten thousand pound will do it
thank you
thank you chairman
um listening to what people have
delivery and they vary depending on the
scope of work the fact that we're having
to resurvey schools at the moment shows
us that very fact that something was
surveyed a year or two ago was surveyed
for one sale criteria there's now a
difference so the scope of work is
actually very important it's for this
Council to determine what they want to
procure within that survey so that's my
first point I think this recommendation
is slightly too vague
and the second point is I agree with my
colleague couch Lefty I'm not convinced
10 000 pounds is going to cut it it may
have done six months ago but the cost of
these surveys has gone through the roof
um excuse the pun because of what's
going on with the Schools supply and
demand has meant that the cost has
literally shot up as well as the delay
in getting these surveys carried out so
my question would be if we cannot
procure a surveyor to carry out the
scope of work that the council agrees
what happens because there's only a
budget of up to ten thousand pounds
um so actually I think councilor
steptoe's Amendment or motion to defer
is possibly a sensible one and one that
will allow this survey to come to
fruition quicker because a more thorough
recommendation can come forward to show
what it's going to include how much it's
going to cost and what the time frame is
on getting a surveyor to actually carry
out because all of those things I have
concerns with at the moment
um so that's why I support councilor
Steptoe thank you thank you potential
[Music]
thank you chairman um councilor Belton
has made the point I was going to make
um ten thousand pounds to me seems to be
pretty insignificant
um due to looking at recent effects I
I happen to know that the survey that
cares uh cleaning and score was for in
excess of 80 000 pounds for a poor
structural survey thank you thank you
Council Hawaii
[Music]
thank you chairman I can now see why
this late with the possessment
administration for so many years with
nothing actually happening
um the officers have given us advice
they are experts in this area they have
said ten thousand pounds I think we've
discussed it quite a lot and can we move
to the vote please
[Music]
so I think I'll have a second for that
um
[Music]
I put a motion forward and you haven't
allowed a seconder to it we hadn't
finished speaking on the motion but I've
put a motion so we have to go on a
motion to put it on the vote please
counselor you sat down you stood up then
you stood up so I'm going to take it in
that order Constable cancer Council and
then we'll go back to council avoidance
I'd like to ask the officer where the
figure of 10 000 pounds came from
um did they go out to any companies for
estimates or is this just a figure
that's been generically done and without
a full estimate of costs I can't see how
we can vote on it therefore I'm in favor
of the amendment
thank you I'm going to take councilor
wood now if you were to make a second
emotion please
thank you chairman
um look I'm tempted to uh make some
cheap comments about semantics about up
to or a budget of or whatever but I will
avoid that
our decisions come from informed
comments in a report
so if I can take members to 3.6.2 it
says a structural survey needs to be
completed
it goes on to say officers will procure
a conditioned survey that will look at
the need of investment required but
focus on exploring options on how to
decarbonize the building
at what cost and what opportunities
I quite understand and particularly over
the last few days can understand why
before putting significant investment
into this this building there would when
people would want an assurance that it
was structurally sound
but I take members back to a series of
emails that existed between
our own in-house surveyor
uh an external surveyor
which conducted a structural survey this
time last year
I think the item that uh
that I've just referred to is
particularly vague
because you're not going to get a
structural survey of this building for
ten thousand pounds or dare I say up to
or a budget of
so we don't really know what the heck
we're talking about in this
recommendation
we need to understand in definitive
terms what we actually want and I don't
think that is actually unreasonable for
us to understand what it is that we're
going to get for our money
if it is to look at the roof structure
as has been mentioned to me with a view
to putting solar panels on the roof in a
Conservation Area
that may be a possibility but let us
understand what it is that we're getting
for a structural survey because ten
thousand pounds in today's market won't
buy you very much so actually I would
appeal to officers not to put us in the
situation as politicians where we don't
have a degree of precision about what it
is that we're actually voting on so that
is why I totally support councilor
Steptoe in his deferral
proposal because all we are asking is to
understand what it is in terms of a
structural survey is it to dig down the
foundations is it to look at concrete is
it to look at the sustainability of this
building what is it to do and then we
could actually come up with some sort of
fear and actually there would be
Universal agreement across the chamber
because we would all want that Assurance
thank you chairman
thank you um I think enough's been said
I think in a very opinion I eat uh
reviews so um
so the thing is that we're going to take
a vote so all those in favor of the
deferment look forward by cancer Steptoe
please indicate
or ask the question of the officer as to
the extent of which
um inquiries had been made around the
ten thousand pounds up to budget and I
don't think I heard an answer so I I
don't want this book to a vote so I've
heard that and I'd like the officer to
explain please what steps were taken to
come to that recommendation thank you
all right
thank you chair we have approached the
independence Fan Company who have
provided us with a quotation of ten
thousand pounds to carry out the works
The Works is to focus primarily on the
roof on the matter around if it was for
over ten thousand pound we have asked
for a budget we can go out and procure
that work if it was for more than that
we would then be coming back anyway to
say so if we are in a position where we
can just progress to get the works
procured we would then come back if it
was more than the ten thousand pound
so members you've had an explanation
here so we can vote on whether or not to
defer for the amendment as put by a
council Steptoe or we refuse so all
those in favor no sorry what do you mean
no sorry I was I
could be
yeah I'm sorry
[Music]
ten thousand primary
lean on the roof
and this is a structural survey so can
you just clarify the 10 000 is that
primarily for a structural survey on the
roof and does it take into account all
the areas that cancer septo has
mentioned
yes I can confirm it is a structural
survey of the roof as previously
mentioned we have had surveys done in
the past and also our internal surveyors
who have looked at the rights of
concrete cancer asbestos in the rules of
that as well so we are taking on all the
work that has been done today and we are
focusing primarily on the roof because
that is where we believe we have not got
as much information as what we need in
order to progress moving this building
forward
so
sorry so can I just understand this is
not a full structural survey this is a
structural survey on the roof you're
gathering information from previous
surveys conducted by the previous
administration and you're putting all
the previous surveys and the conditional
survey together to come up with your
um overall condition of the building in
terms of its structure
um
sorry can I ask for amendment that that
reads structural survey on the roof
I think I think and that's being said
you can form your own opinions right so
we're going to go to this boat and I
want don't want any interruptions we're
going to go to this boat as put forward
by councilor Steptoe and it's been
prosecutive by cancer Worton so all
those you in favor of it be firmative
for further detail please indicate now
okay
thank you all those you against
[Music]
thank you members any abstentions
members is 11 4 23 against and so and
two abstentions so that has been refused
so we go shall we go back to the
original
um
um motion as book before R5 that the
budget shop I tend to council McPherson
thank you chairman therefore just for
clarity could we have a small amendment
to that
recommendation saying that it is a
structural survey of the roof of the
Mill Hall art and Event Center chairman
if I have a secondary education
I'd like to thank you Joe
Council Christine Mason Mrs Christina
thank you chair I'm a little bit
confused because I thought that the
clarity given by the officer and the
clarity and the report I can't
understand why it seems very simple to
me and yet the members on the other side
seem to have such difficulty item three
six two a structural survey needs to be
completed on the building taking account
of the building conditions survey
completed in September 22. my
application that's the previous
information
officers of her condition so they look
at the need of the investment required
but also focus on exploring options to
decarbonize now it I admit it doesn't
say the roof but you have all seen the
original condition survey so if the only
thing outstanding is the roof what we're
doing here the suggestion is to pick up
the missing bits and that's all that's
for so that's the structural survey if
we put roof in you're restricting it to
just the roof if they look at the roof
and they find they need to look at
something else then obviously we need
them to do that so I I really think that
this motion is straightforward is a
budget and it should be approved thank
you
submission Fusion
thank you chairman
um my main reason for simply adding roof
would be to speed things up as I'm sure
that people would then hopefully
supported thank you chairman
thank you chairman I'd also like to add
we've got some new councilors and this
year who would not have seen
surveys completed in September uh 2022
so could I ask that the officers
actually send them out to all the
counselors because some counselors have
not seen them thank you so it's
difficult to make an informal decision
okay
[Music]
sure we've got this amendment on our
Second Amendment chairman 90 seconds
again
all right
right so that most that amendment has
been what so can you repeat the
amendment please
chairman quite simply it was
a little roof after structural survey of
the roof of the mill arts and events
center only for clarity only to speed
this up and that was all thank you right
may we take about their members all
those in favor of that Amendment
thank you
thank you very much any abstentions
remember that's uh 12 4 23 against and
one abstention therefore that
amendment's lost
so we'll go back to the original member
original
um have the proposal counteractic
Jim I have a question for the officer is
there I'm looking for the report sorry
I'm looking for the report I can't see a
time scale on these surveys
I might reset
[Music]
following approval of the budget we will
go out to procurement straight away
sorry I've got meat in my mouth and
we're quite procurement straight away
um and it will be dependent on quotes
time scales of the independence of
layers as well but it will be carried
out as soon as possible that I can
reasonably do
it therefore we're now going to vote on
an R5 then the budget of up to 10 000
pounds is allocated to a structural
service arts and Event Center all those
in favor
thank you
thank you members those against
thank you members any abstentions
cool
thank you very much
members that is 24 4 6 against
and six abstentions so that's carried
we're going to R6 now then that the
draft market research objectives are
approved enabling officers to proceed
procure and conduct the research
Council HD
thank you thank you chairman so it um
got a slight Amendment if that's number
six I've seen six yeah uh reading which
says that the draft market research
objectives and and a budget because we
ask the officers if they've got any idea
what this would actually cost because
looking at the objectives and the amount
of people they want to go and ask
questions of across the district it
could be quite a lot of money and I'm
not saying we shouldn't spend the money
because we need to be informed uh just
like some idea what it would cost and if
and I'd like to recommend such a
recommendation of the budget of 50K
thank you
currently um as proposed at the previous
executive in March there's a budget
allocated of 25
000 which is being funded from the
community investment plan uh preserved
council Mrs Belton
[Music]
thank you
talk about going to around 2 000 people
I believe across the whole District can
I ask
essentially what are we looking for that
we didn't get before from research that
was done from research that was put in
from Save The Mill Hall and the
independent guy Colin I apologize I
can't remember the organization that he
was from but he gave a big report on
what the Mill Hall usage should be
um I wonder what we're looking for and
obviously the further the further east
we go into the district the further the
views will vary from what people want to
use the Mill Hall for which gives me
concerns and point six within the
objective is explore other potential
opportunities and uses uses for the site
which brings me right back to
recommendation 1A where I had concerns
about the word community be limited
because this implies if the research
comes back and it's not favorable to
keep in the Arts and events center for
Arts events and Community we could be
back with something completely different
on the table so a little bit of
reassurance as to what why and when
would be helpful and if the original 20
5K budget that was set is still
significant given that we want to do the
entire district and reach at least 2 000
people thank you chair
like any comments
so the purpose of the Market's research
which people um
suggest people take into account all the
research that we have had done today but
following the eor process it was very
clear that
um
the two preferred Partners there was a
lack of information we as a council was
able to give them the direction of
travel for this building therefore the
purpose of the market research is
obvious is highlighted
under 3.5 for the research objectives
and supports the objectives that have
been set in recommendations from 1A
which is to focus primarily on this
field to be an arts and event center and
how we make that a successful Arts
events center reducing the financial
um
how the council subsidizing this
building was currently we are
subsidizing this subsidizing this
building financially
five hundreds of thousands and it's not
sustainable for the long term so the
purpose of this market research is to
and is to gather and inform as much
information as possible to present a
strong business case going forward
Finance community and there may be some
difficult questions or scenarios that
can come out of that but that is to
presented to members to to make that to
make that judgment
gosh
thank you thank you Phoebe
um so if I may just come back just to
just to confirm because explore other
potential opportunities and uses for the
site does that mean any other
opportunities and uses for the site
because that's again how it reads and
this is just about Clarity and making
sure we're voting for the right thing
thank you
um no so it's not a broad what options
could there be obviously the objects
have been set is the primary focus is to
arts and incentives so it's how do we
bring arts and events back in back into
back into early back into this building
how do we get not only the residents of
these districts but
um other boroughs and that coming into
already bringing in that tourism
bringing in that support
um to bring in that Financial commercial
kind of arm around it to help subsidize
what we are putting on from this
building
okay
thank you chair
um I'd just like to say that uh
councilor Belton
um I understand where you're coming from
however this is a really important piece
of work this will be the first time this
number of our community would have been
reached in such a wide area which is why
my comments to start off with I talked
about rich in a really wide and
all-inclusive demographic you are quite
right we won't be excluding anybody
however what we really really need to do
is to make sure that we know how our
residents are going to support this
building long term so that we can get
this right and have this building
financially sustainable not just for the
council but actually for the residents
okay thank you
[Music]
thank you chairman
um council Mrs Wilson refers there to
the demographic and those that are going
to be
um survey can I ask how extensive that
survey will be will it include those
people that live in places like found s
or great white green
who very rarely
have the opportunity to use this
facility here but of course we'll have
to be paying for it out of their rates
so I'd like some clarification as to
does does Mrs Wilson cast Mrs Wilson
mean that it's just the local area
the greater area or the whole District
can we have some clarification now
please
council Mrs Wilson
thank you chair uh in response to
councilman Steptoe as I said uh in my
opening ramble
um and actually it's in the report that
because we want to reach so many and
such a wide area
um we don't just want people from
Rayleigh who can jump on the bus or
manage to get up crown or London Hill uh
to uh walk here to see us so announce
what your question is I cannot guarantee
every resident in great Waker in will be
surveyed however the whole point of
having this market research done
um in such a wide area that has never
been done before certainly as far as
Mill Hall is concerned is to make sure
we get as many opinions
um as is possible to make this a success
that is our sole Focus thank you
cancer Stanley
thank you chairman it's obvious that
our wall counselors can explore
what
the mill arts and events center is for
and it's for our wall counselors to
promote what Rochford Council does in
their areas and I would suggest that
councilor Steptoe should start promoting
just that thank you
thank you man Bush I think we've had a
long discussion on this and I think the
point's been well raised and I think now
we should take a vote and uh we have a
motion on the floor and and I will
repeat it for you that the draft market
research objectives are approved
enabling officers to proceed and conduct
the research now all those in favor of
that please indicate
natural motion I gave a budget of 50 000
again
okay put your range down I want you to
do you've got are you put the proposal
in
come on
you can't have a situation where we put
a motion to debate and discussion and
then at the end of it we discover we
haven't seconded it but we'll just
suddenly second it that's not acceptable
as I said earlier
the motion failed
it is not to be put
point of openness the chairman points of
order members I use I'm taking advice
for the mo
thank you
thank you chairman and apologies uh
members and those watching for the the
brief pause there while we just
consulted amongst the statutory officers
um cancer FD apologies it wasn't clear
that you were proposing that as an
amendment
um just consulted with the section 151
officer there is a budget already in
existence for this work of 25 000 pounds
I've been advised that if the council
wishes to move that that's increased to
50 000 pounds that is possible there are
reserves or alternative budgets that
could be used to fund that additional 25
000 subject to the council's approval
thank you chair
[Music]
Mr chairman
I have a raging headache tonight I don't
feel particularly well and I would like
a glass of water
but what I take great exception to is
the Outburst of behavior by the leader
who frankly should know better and
slamming his hands down on this is not
becoming to graceful behavior and I
really ask you to seek an apology for
that unnecessary Outburst thank you Mr
chairman
what is unnecessary
are the series of amendments that have
been brought forward which are which are
simply about filibustering so in point
of older Mr chairman gentlemen members
please let's all sit down now and then
let's get back to where we were thank
you Miss Mason I'll take everyone please
sit down thank you
right we will now get on with the
matters in hand and we're going to go
back to our six yeah couldn't you just
enlighten me well did we have a proposal
proposal from councilor FD but we need a
seconder cancer sparing seconds
emotionally therefore we went outside so
can I make a point of order
I'm sorry Mr chairman and I'm going to
disagree
commissioned 50 000 he did not get a
seconder we have spent the last 10 or 15
minutes debating R6 the motion on the
paper you can't when we're going to hook
that suddenly take an amendment the
amendment was not put in a timely
fashion it was not correct so I would
like that checked because if councilor
FD had had a second and we would have
been speaking to his Amendment but we
weren't we were speaking to the
substantive motion then we asked for
that to be put and then all of a sudden
we find a seconder that is unacceptable
way of conducting business
[Music]
Mr chairman if you will indulge me again
to to just advise the council
um I completely take on board councilman
Mrs Mason's point but I think what we
have here is an unfortunate case of a
misunderstanding that the intention was
to propose an amendment and chair I
think the interests of fairness that
amendment should be uh now taken given
that councilor FD has pointed out that
he intended it to be uh treated as an
amendment to the recommendations right
I'll take the advice of my my mentoring
officer um so you've put that proposal
can you just repeat that again please
thank you chairman The Proposal was that
the draft market research objectives and
a budget of 50 000 pounds are approved
United officers proceed with the conduct
of research
experience
so we've gone we've got the proposal
within that
the the sorry can you repeat it again so
we can vote clearly
what is your promotion
okay chairman that the draft market
research and draft market research
objectives and a budget of 50k are
approved enabling office to procure and
conduct the research
right there but we're proposing a second
there
we've done that
one yeah
thank you chairman and we're speaking to
the amendment that's just been put I
won't be supporting that Amendment
chairman that figure's just been plucked
out the air
the 25 000 has been fully costed for 50
000 I don't know where that figures come
from but that's just Reckless Financial
mismanagement thank you
that's a bad one
[Music]
thank you
um
we didn't when that 25 000 pound budget
was set back in March I believe we
didn't have this set of objectives that
covered such a vast amount of research a
vast amount of research that we wholly
support
um I think councilors before have
brought it up on LNF that market
research needs to be done valuable and
constructive market research needs to be
done now I also understand from
conversations with officers and others
that that includes the council's
cultural offering to enable The Mill
Hall to look at Grants and future
opportunities and it also officer said
that the partners needed more market
research were formally concluded with
the partners yet we're taking the advice
for the more market research it's a bit
conflicting but the reason that 50 000
pound has been suggested is because it's
our belief from our conversations and
our research that to do this properly 25
000 pounds won't cut the six objectives
that have been set here it may have cut
the market research that we originally
planned to do back in March but this
Administration was to do more we support
that we support taking that research far
and wide but we don't think 25 pounds is
going to see the results that this
Administration want so that is why it's
not plucked out of the sky it's
thoughtful and it was an amendment that
was made originally and secondly very
good well now we've got the proposal
we've had a full understanding of what
is proposal has been suggested so we're
going to take a vote and I'm going to
take a vote so all those in favor of
that amendment by Council FD
thank you all those against
thank you members any upstations
no
members that's four four eleven against
25 abstention zero so that's uh has been
turned down we now go back to R6 is the
original at the draft market research
objectives are approved enabling
officers to proceed and conduct the
research move that from the floor casual
fds
thank you chairman can't just ask a
question the officer like on the last
motion will the officer come back to
full Council if they need more money
[Music]
yes if it's outside the budget I'd come
back to council
I haven't got a check in it yet
so we've already debated all of this
yeah right we're going to go over the
same territory I'll give Mr Steptoe one
more go and then we're going to call a
vote yeah
thank you chairman I'm still very
concerned about who is going to be
surveyed in the documentation somewhere
it says around 2 000 people we do have
86 000 people within our district
and I'm very concerned that the people
down the Eastern end of the district
whether that be canoon or paglishment
great white ring or wherever are simply
going to be left out of this particular
situation so I'm very concerned about
that and I'd like summer assurance that
this will be carried out throughout the
whole district and anybody that has
wants to give an opportunity to respond
to this survey has the opportunity to do
so
thank you we'll now take a vote
so we'll take a vote then so um
cash cash a Newport
I just want to um reassure councilor
Steptoe that I'm sure part of this will
be done online and that will reach
worldwide so I'm sure it will reach
Canadian thank you
well we can you've all heard what's been
said you've got your opinions we can
carry it out by vote so all those in
favor of that proposition
s but the draft market research
objectives are approved enabling
officers to proceed and conduct the
research which is the original
motion so all those in favor of them
against
it's all unanimous that was any
abstentions
unanimous
members that was your unanimous
well we're going to R7 at the following
following the conclusion the market
research engagement activity and
structural survey options for the future
operation of the Mill Hall and Event
Center are presented back to the full
council with a full supporting business
case
[Music]
um 3.6
3.6.3 can we please have it amended to
Spring 2024 not Sprint
because I don't think we're going to be
in a Sprint race thank you
It's been a 74. I see typing error
thank you
okay
[Music]
would it be possible
Commendation is there but there's no
time frame on it and it just feels
open-ended there's a suggestion in the
report to Spring 24 but why not put it
in a recommendation so we have some
definition on when we're likely to see
that you want to put that as an
amendment I'm happy to ask my colleagues
first because if they're happy to to
change it I'll accept that it's just
this is about getting things done right
okay Mrs Wilson
thank you chair
um the reason why an unread historic
councilor Belton actually I don't want
to date in there is because I'm really
hoping we can come in before that the
intention is to certainly not come in
any later than that which is why the
date is in report personally I don't
think it needs to be on the amendment
because I don't want anyone dragging
their feet in the same to me but it says
we don't have to do it just bring 24.
thank you thank you Mr hook Council hoy
um I don't need to speak now councilor
Mrs Wilson to check what I was going to
say Felton thank you I do accept
counselor bill merson's
uh we're allowing that time frame and
actually put it in the recommendation
should make that more of a hard date in
my opinion
um like I said I'm not going to put
forward for an amendment because it'll
be a waste of everybody's time but I
wanted to make the point because we want
to see this come to conclusion and put
in a date of fire spring 2024 means it
has to be by then or before so it would
support what councilor Wilma Wilson did
just say but we'll leave it there I'm
sure Mrs Castle which is real soon that
there will be every effort to do that
but to bring it forward as soon as
possible so there's certainly
okay
so
we'll take that term I
thought we moved again
so we take r10 R7 then do I I'm moving
from four Drive signal
cancer Mrs Mason sorry I'm not point of
order this the whole R1 to R7 were
proposed by a councilor Mrs Wilson and I
second bit okay
well then we turned the vote in that are
so in the following conclusion of the
market research and gave an activity and
structural survey options for the future
operations arts and Event Center I
present you back to the full council
with a supporting business case so all
those in favor
against
any abstentions
that has been unanimously couldn't agree
right can we move on
yeah
we've been going for two
I request that we have a small company
right please some of us need facilities
I'm mindful of that but I'm going to
take because of the time because we're
gonna I'm gonna have to go into another
session in a minute asking for an
Extinction so
if we're going to do this then we're
going to have to start researching for
further time because we're going to be
extending as long as you're aware then
I'm a diabetics
sure yeah
I'm actually a diabetic so I need a
conflict now
okay we're going to take five minutes
and then we'll come back so the time
there is 9 29.
thank you
foreign
then most of the time now it's 9 36 and
I now reconvene this meeting
now we're going to back to the agenda
and we're now going to have item 16
members of the public questions and um
I will now invite Mrs Miss Jill wait to
present a question to the leader
push the button
thank you chairman for granting me this
opportunity to speak at full Council and
for speaking earlier in the evening I
appreciate that so my question is to the
leader in regards to item nine which is
the exempt report
from the asset delivery program
councilor Mason you personally have
championed transparency and openness on
what basis do you believe the public
interest in maintaining the exemption
outweighs the public interest in
disclosing the information in the exempt
report thank you thank you thank you Mrs
White yeah
so for this please can I ask for the
council leader professor John Mayer
I know I'm sure I have a child like
humans
thank you Shannon
um Miss White
I'm sorry not to be facing you but the
protocol is to face the champ
Ms Waite thank you for your question
which rightly holds the joint
Administration to account on our pledges
for openness and transparency
you will hear shortly in my introduction
to the next item the reason why this
item must be held in closed session
however in response to your specific
question
the council has received legal advice
that the council's commercial position
could be disadvantaged if the item is
discussed in public
and therefore there is a distinct public
interest in withholding disclosure at
this point in the process thank you
thank you
well before we go any further I'm going
to read this out to the meeting and it's
uh as last year roughly two hours
so remember the region is now last
lasted roughly two hours I would like to
move the motion without notice according
to the council procedure rule 14 in to
extend the meeting beyond the two and a
half hours for as long as necessary in
order to complete the remaining business
can I have a secondary
yes
can those in favor please raise their
hands
thank you members
those against
thank you members any abstentions
thank you very much
the 23 for the motion 12 against and one
abstinction therefore that motion is
carried
we are extended
[Music]
Michigan
thank you chairman um you said as long
as it takes yeah
hence I abstained okay because
um
the first items taken quite considerable
time and there's several more on here is
there no time limit no no in answer to
that thank you
members I would never invite cancer
John Mason to speak on this item
okay
I've ordered Mr chairman uh I'd like to
refer to the Constitution
15.12 page 4.14
and I haven't noticed here that I would
like to read out with your permission
Please Mr chairman under part four of
the Rochford District Council
Constitution rules of procedure section
3.1 page 4.4 dated the 25th of January
2022 we the underside of being
conservative members of the Russian
District Council are calling for an
extraordinary council meeting to be held
as soon as it is reasonably practicable
with the intention to have as the sole
item on its agenda item 9 on Council
agenda dated 7th of September 2023
namely the asset delivery program and
consequently this item deferred until
when
and the reasons for this are the 402
page lengthy reports relating to item 9
was issued late on Wednesday the 30th of
August it is highly detailed and more
time is needed for it to be read and
understood unreasonable time needs to be
given to provide Clarity on issues
raised before important decisions are
made
also at that time a number of members
were on holiday during what is
traditionally a holiday period in this
country and for the council
my second point is the importance and
complexity of the subject and the desire
where possible to achieve political
consensus gives weight to it being a
single item agenda where time permits
for proper and thorough debates
the third point is as a matter of good
practice we believe the report's content
should be subject to pre-scrutiny where
questions can be researched and answered
within a reasonable time frame
especially given the complexity of the
subject and the significant impact any
decisions made have on Rochford District
residents and my final point is whilst
respecting that some of the report
content is commercially sensitive we
strongly disagree on this side with the
whole report being dealt with as an
exempt item including all of the
recommendations
as well as under the relevant sections
on exempting attendance by the press and
public under the Local Government Act 19
1972 could be legally challenged in this
case by means of judicial review in any
event we believe this is at significant
variance with the principles of open
governance which should be where at all
possible be seen to be concluded openly
and in a transparent fashion
to do so otherwise creates the wrong
perception in the minds of the residents
we serve and should consequently be
avoided if at all possible and with that
Mr chairman I have 12 signatures to call
for an extraordinary meeting would you
like me to hand it to you now Mr
chairman
thank you um chairman and thank you
councilor Wooten for the opportunity to
delve into some of the finer points of
the Constitution and chairman my advice
to you is that the requisition to call a
meeting an extraordinary meeting on its
own is valid and that should be
submitted to you however it's not valid
to also add the deferral into that
requisition so the correct process would
be to move a motion without notice under
procedural 14 uh
foreign
and there's a number of different
options that we can use there I can
advise on that depending on what you
want to achieve
um and then if that motion to defer or
to adjourn the meeting is then passed
the requisition to call the
extraordinary then comes into play so
that's the advice chair they can't be
done in a single motion
[Music]
Mr chairman it is a quarter of 10 at
night we are just about to enter into
debating a 402 page Report with
recommendations do you in all honesty
consider that it is a reasonable request
to have extended the meeting at all it's
just a simple point I'm a simple chap
but I do have a bedtime and I would like
to get the bed because I like a number
of us in the morning have to be
outreachably early I think it's just
totally unreasonable to expect due
process to take place over a 402 page
report
[Music]
Michael
debate at this stage
yes we don't have a proposal as such on
what to debate so I'm only a major point
but is there a proposal made here
I think I may be quite clear Mr chairman
I'm proposing that we defer and I would
like to actually call an extraordinary
meeting if the technicalities of that
need to be slightly worth it there is
the document with 12 signatures on it
which is a way exceeds the requirement
for an extraordinary I understand I just
need a formal approach presentation so
that someone can second it
yeah
so we'll take a photo whether we would
go through your proposition
so members it's been proposed that we
defer this to a special meeting to
discuss and refer to the agenda items
are correct right so all those in favor
over this said do Furman please indicate
accordingly
thank you those against
[Music]
yeah
thank you any extensions
then their members there was 12 4 23
against and one abstention therefore
that most that proposition has been
declared so councilman estimation with
bacteria
and um
I'm not sure if I heard during councilor
wooten's last address that there was a
challenge
to
the proposal to place the meeting into
into exempt and excluding the press and
public
um can that be can you can you can we
please be reminded on what the challenge
was please
and then when I've heard the challenge
I'd like to ask the monitoring officer
to respond
counselor one who put the last
recommended proposals forward
Mr chairman I think it best if I hand
you uh the complete report and you can
look at this it's probably a little
difficult for you on the stage but it is
actually the point four that I read out
but if I may I'll hand it to you
yeah let's just be with this couple of
seconds while we read this
Mr chairman the uh proposal from
councilor Wootton
um essentially talks about the uh
commercially sensitive parts of the
report and a disagreement that the whole
report needs to be dealt with in closed
session and there's a query that
potentially the the council could be
subject to a judicial review should we
erroneously go into closed session
um chairman we have had legal advice
that was very strong and told us that
this debate should be taken in closed
session to protect the interests of the
council
um I support that advice as your
monitoring officer and I urge the the
council to take that advice seriously
um chairman you have the opportunity to
vote on the exclusion of the public and
press and that's your point to
demonstrate your disagreement if you
disagree with that approach
um and chair it would be
um unusual I think on a procedural point
for the council to be legally challenged
over that exclusion if it was Julie if
it was Julie made and Julie voted on
thank you chair
okay so we go back to artemit then thank
you for that and Mr Mason would you like
to continue or would you have anything
further to say
[Music]
Mr
but there are a number of other items on
the agenda which the public can be in
attendance
if we're going to ask the public to
leave now I think it's extremely
unreasonable to expect then to have to
wait outside why we go through this
extremely lengthy
document for this particular writer so
can I suggest to you Mr Ken that perhaps
those items that the public can say
are dealt with
so and then the public then leaves
and don't have to stand around waiting
for us to debate 400 Pages Mr steps I'll
tell you point but it isn't really a
point
I'll take your point but it's not really
a point of order it's your opinion so we
go back to Mr Mason again too
look I'm not going to go on with this
well I've had advice from my
monitoring officer who is well skilled
and legally trained in all of this and
we've had legal advice on this matter
and we will now take it to a vote to go
into extended session so if I can come
back to you Mr councilmation
thank you chairman
um I do want to say a few words before I
move that we go to exclude
the press and the public
um members I'm sure like me you would
have very much hoped that this important
debate on the future of our strategic
assets could have been held in public
session
however we have received as you've just
heard legal advice which has advised us
in the strongest terms to consider the
whole of this report in closed session
as it contains sensitive commercial
information
in order to protect this council's
interests and ultimately those of our
residents I believe we must follow this
advice
however
this joint Administration made a
commitment to open and transparent
democracy and I will personally I will
personally ensure that the public are
kept informed about our proposals as
soon as it is possible to do so
on that basis chairman I so moved the
exclusion of the press and public the
public and press as printed under item a
to the agenda thank you so I wish I
could okay
thank you chairman I'll second that okay
the members we have a proposition to
exclude the members of the public and
press all those in favor please indicate
thank you
thank you members
those against
thank you members any abstentions
three thank you members
well the vote is those four 24 those
against ten and two abstentions we
therefore now we're going for the um
the exclusion of all members of the
public and press from this room while we
continue and can I ask that you can
can I ask that the cameras be
look at the canals that the livestream
came has been prevented but we'll keep
the microphones on for the benefit of
members and those for hearing
thank you
foreign
sir sorry chairman
make my excuses
thank you as long as we've got a quorum
I don't mind
[Music]
now as I propose that we re-admit the
public and press all those in favor
thank you any against
thank you right
can you restart the streaming thank you
we'll now take a gender item 11 review
of the blood Friday committee
um
thank you chairman I'll be very quick
with this introduction members I think
the report is self-explanatory it
proposes the dissolution of the flood
Advisory Group and the creation of a new
flood working group with the remit
described in the report the proposal has
been developed following a review by
members of the existing flood advisory
Advisory Group that was a cross-party
review and I would like to thank those
councilors and officers who were
involved in undertaking that work
chairman I'm happy to take any questions
and I would like to now hand over to you
councilor Stanley to propose the
recommendations thank you Mr Stanley
yes thank you chairman
um I'd like to recommend the
flood
Advisory Group to be adopted by Roxford
Council thank you
so are you proposing all three uh
recommendations yes okay there's a
second
council Mrs Mason
thank you chair I would like to propose
that the three recommendations are
focused on and block and accepted
um thank you
thank you I've got a number of questions
on this
so I won't keep it up I don't really
don't worry
um Can someone clarify that the
rationale for naming the appointees I've
not had done a particular problem but
normally we will say three members and
this then restricts us to three named
members
I see council Mrs Mason's gonna answer
so I'll leave it there thank you yeah I
will clarify that the the flood working
group has been working
um with those three members at the boat
so it's a continuation of the existing
situation which will change
with the new Council
so it's it's just to continue formally
continue what's been going on
for the this year and in May it will
then become a working group of one of
the new committees and the three members
will then be acquainted thank you thank
you Council
[Music]
um
a Rockford District Council is not the
lead to flood Authority in this
particular case which is actually asset
account for Council
uh can I ask how uh we're going to be
working with Essex Capital Council on
this particularly around enforcement
which is something that needs to be
considered in getting various drains and
things uh unblocked
um how does that work and where is the
connection between the two organizations
Stanley do you want to reply to that
thank you chairman
um
only uh yesterday
I was with the Essex County Council
flood Forum uh Consulting with them and
advised them of a new situation that
we've got and they were more than happy
to take advice take take our uh advice
as well on the flooding in the area we
are working with issu's care to council
as we are working with all of the
councils and that includes Basildon
Brentwood and everybody else in the way
water is managed thank you
you want you to say something
thank you chairman um just for
clarification and I don't know if I saw
it in the report
the existing issues that the flood Forum
were dealing with are they all going to
be transferred over to the new working
group to deal with and progress
yes they will be passed over but if you
look at it what we're doing at the
moment we're the the flood Advisory
Group has not been effective or should
we say it's not been as effective as we
would like so the system has changed
that when there's more focus on things
where we can make a difference but
following up so yes they will initially
go over but eventually hopefully they'll
be resolved
you want to do
yes I apologize I'm not sure if I made
my question clear
um will Essex County Council be acting
on behalf of Rochester District Council
to carry out the enforcement and have
they agreed in principle to do that
okay thank you Stanley
thank you chairman
um I believe that uh Essie's Council are
the enforcement uh operatives that will
do the enforcement we are Advisory Group
and we would advise as to where that
work needs to be done and work with sfk
to cancel any enforcement if necessary
thank you
thank you chairman
um it says that this is going to meet
bi-monthly which is great it says that
it's going to be three free permanent
members which is great
it says all councilors were invited to
have an open invitation but in the past
when it's been twice early I've never
known when it's happening so how will
that be advertised to all members and
how do we go about if you want to turn
up
will that be advertised tell us how to
do that thanks go to Stanley
uh thank you Council ft
um yes we're asking all councilors to
involve themselves in the flooding areas
that is appertaining to their areas to
bring it back to the advisory forum and
and then we can deal with the matters
what is happening in their area
the idea is that we would
prioritize
areas that need to be worked on quicker
rather than having a full
documentary of every area all at the
same time if it is deemed to be a
urgent case then we will deal with that
in the urgency that we need to with this
is Council I do hope that's answered
your question
[Music]
I just come back to just uh for
understanding so if we have a problem we
get in touch with one of the three
permanent members who will take it
forward and we can just come and listen
to see what happens is that correct
yes that is correct Gem and if you'd
like to come back to any one of us that
and without that's the reason why
there's three it it melts to be a better
system and more collaboration with the
wall councilors thank you
objections are there to take all three
um
recommendations in one vote are you all
happy to do so yeah
right and then the proposition is on the
floor that we resolve these and vote on
these motions all those in favor
thank you anything anything against
any abstentions
that motion is carried thank you
there we go on to item 12 I think is
absolutely
in the absence of German affairs and
cannot sleep counselor Nick Booth as
well right
they should hear that we're not lost Mr
German fission but she's left on this uh
to consider a report from the executive
or other commit account answers
there are four reports I agenda write
M12 report the average scrutiny
committee Mrs McPherson is not here
Catholic person is not here so
um can I call upon we've got here
councilor Stuart Wilson
chairman I'll be brief as it's late at
night
um probably the key document that we
work to on RNs is the work plan and the
work plan last year was very Dynamic we
had set
um areas that we investigated but we
actually brought forward a number of
items at the request of General members
um and also members of the committee
um a couple of pieces of work that I
think the committee did really well was
that we
um in conjunction with the chief
executive and with the then leader of
the council asked for a review
independent review of the ADP program
and I think that worked really well it
was a good good piece of work
um another piece that I'd like to
highlight is the in November it was the
report on a review of enforcement in
Rochford district and again I'd like to
thank council Mrs McPherson and
councilor Mike Wilkinson for the work
that they did indeed in the task and
finish group
um and then
um finally what I'd like to do is just
say we we had more external bodies that
we got in and that was through the hard
work of Sonia and Veronica making
contact with these people and really
trying to get them in
um and then finally I'd like to thank
all the members who served on the
committee whether they were there as
full-time members of the committee or as
substitutes and also the officers for
their support as well so that is my
report chairman thank you okay remember
uh are there any questions at this stage
thank you right remember so there is one
recommendation set in paragraph one two
on page 12 11 1 of the report and that
is to note the overview and scrutiny
committee annual report for the 2022 to
2023 Municipal year is that noted
members
thank you
the gender item 1212 report the other
room security committee treasury
management annual review
um
let me show you my faces in here so uh
snake who will that be
counselor please
chairman
are you in a position to make a comment
in a moment no I don't feel what I am
well we haven't got anybody to put that
video should we defer that version until
the next question
something that needs to be proposed it's
just if any member wants to talk to it
okay
um it comes under my lead membership I
don't know I mean I'm aware of the
treasury management document I I've
reviewed the current line I can comment
on it if you want to or if you need
someone from our destiny which I suspect
is probably the case well I'll be honest
with you I mean I'm in mindful just to
take a you know if everybody's uh you
know are okay with it or if they've got
any questions I mean it's up to you
really if you feel you need to make a
comment by all means
do you need to make a comment
[Music]
by councilor um Mr Wilson just said he's
happy to make a comment and he was a
chair of the committee for that year
that's right now in that case then uh if
there's no other questions then it's
recommended that uh recommend check that
in paragraph one two on page 12 3-1 of
the report
um the local plan development screen
2023-2025 are attached to the appendix
too oh I've jumped ahead I nearly got a
vote we're showing Nelson
that's it honey they've got something
through
right remember so we're not doing it
right we've done all this anyway members
there is one recommendation saying
paragraph one three on page 12 2-1 of
the report to note the contents of the
treasury menu in 2022 2023 annual report
members this is noted thank you
right a gender item 12-3 Report with a
planning policy committee local plan
development scheme 2023 to 2020.5 and
I've not revived councilor Jim Cripps to
introduce his report
thank you chairman
the local development scheme is a formal
document that sets out a forward
timetable for the preparation of
development plan documents and other
core planning documents this report
consists of an update to the council's
local development scheme covering the
period 23 to 25.
the two recommendations
R1 is a single piece of paper which is a
bar chart showing the
diagram diagrammatically showing the way
forward with what we're doing and R2 is
the actual paper document with the body
of the information
so I'd like to propose that R1 and R2
are accepted for publication in the
council's website
attention nipple
yes chairman I'd like to second that
are there any questions
there'll be no questions members there
we've got a proposal on a gender item
room and all those in favor
thank you members to the country
any abstentions one abstention
then that motion is carried
well item 12-3 report of the planning
policy committee local plane development
scheme
2023-2001. I've just done that one yeah
item 12-4 Report with the standards
committee standards committee working
group right invite Mrs Deborah
Schoolhouse Coleman to introduce this
report
thank you chair
um at its meeting on your 20th thank you
at this meeting on the 22nd of August
2023 the standards committee was mindful
that the composition of the standards
committee working group and its terms of
reference had not been Revisited since
the 12th of December 2017. it was
therefore deemed appropriate to ask
Council to to consider a revised
membership of the working group together
with revised terms of reference
it's it's proposed that the Council of
resolves to appoint a cross-party
standards committee working group
consisting of councilors Lawman Linden
and sharp
and councilor sparing as the now named
conservative member
it is also proposed that the terms of
reference for the working group be set
as stated in the standards committee
report
I now propose that this Council approved
these recommendations
I'd like to second that recommendation
did you want to speak
any questions
thank you chairman and I'll give this
caveat I don't mean this in a personal
manner
um but I note that you are down as a
member of the committee as chairman of
the council
is that constitutionally correct
when I was chairman Vice chairman I was
told I couldn't be on stance committee
foreign
[Music]
chairman I've just referred to the
articles of the Constitution and I can't
see any uh Provisions that would prevent
you from being a member of that
committee or that working group thank
you
[Music]
for clarity could I just ask that if
there was any anything taken place that
I would be in the position of appeal or
anything like this as a chairman so
someone came back with on it at any
point so I'll be basically
free from any of those commitments thank
you
[Music]
oh sorry are you right okay
thank you chairman sir I did have a note
from Emily that I've been seen
um I I just want to raise
um item one says cross party
it has a member of
as the chairman has two different
practicum unconservative
um our appointee to the standards
committee was not able to attend that
meeting
and hasn't
in talking to her not being tonight been
asked for two
to see if she wants to be part of the
working group
um so I'm a bit concerned that we've we
as a group of effective being excluded
from that group what can I ask why
to Mrs Mason
my understanding of cross-party and I'm
sure the monetary office will correct me
if I'm wrong is that it has more than
one party not all parties the standard
committee wanted a small effective
committee we also watch for district
residents don't have a representative on
that working group we don't have a
problem with it I do think that it's not
a case of excluding someone it's a case
of
um
inviting people that have got the time
and the commitment to do the work and it
will be quite intense
sorry I was expecting an answer from the
chairman of the commercial advisor but
I'll expect to accept counselor
Mrs Mason's response as she's a member
of the committee
um I'm sure we might look at that later
but I'll leave that for now thank you
image well you're happy to take these
recommended recommendations on block
therefore members I would like to
take the boat in all those in favor of
these recommendations
thank you members those against
thank you any abstentions
that that recommendation has been
approved
now we're up to item 13 I hope
uh item 13 a verbal update on the
Constitutional working group and I'd
like to call and invite councilor James
Newport to provide to the Council of
verbal update on the Constitution
working group
thank you chairman um I know this is a
verbal update but I think I will um
distribute this to member services so
they can pass it around to the um
conservatives who have left uh
prematurely
um as chairman of the Constitution
working group I am pleased to update
members on the work we have undertaken
so far to develop a proposal for a
committee structure and to fully review
the Constitution
so far we've held two meetings and I've
had our third meeting scheduled for next
week the working group has already
produced a proposed committee structure
which includes a number of regulatory
committees the scrutiny committee and a
policy and policy committees and are
developing the terms of reference for
each of these committees
we have reviewed parts of the
Constitution the Articles and have
provided the monitoring officer with a
steer to redraft part three of the
Constitution responsibility for
functions this is this includes the
schemes of officers delegations
chairman the working group is on track
to meet the deadline set out by full
Council and in our work program
namely that the committee structure were
brought before will be brought before
Council for agreement in December 2023
and that the revised complete
Constitution will be brought forward for
approval in February 2024.
we will be considering how we engage in
brief members on the proposals ahead of
those meetings
this review is an intensive piece of
work at pace which requires a lot of
input
both at the meetings
and as homework
I would like to thank my fellow working
group members for the time they've
committed to this important piece of
work and they're valued contributions
thank you thank you
for that remember to watch on 14
business from last council meeting there
are no business held over the last one
no business over the last meeting uh
item 15 reported the leader of the work
of the executive Council domination
yeah thank you chairman I I think it's
important to recognize the amount of
work that the executive are doing and I
am happy to give this report and I will
provide member services a copy tomorrow
so that they can incorp into the minutes
just to run through what's happening at
the executive committee on the 21st of
September we're going to receive a
report on Castle Hall which is the
remaining asset that we haven't
attempted to discuss this evening and
there will be a business case
um quarterly budget monitoring which of
course will have been received initially
by
opioids scrutiny but goes to the
committee the modern slavery act review
environmental service plan and some
members will be very pleased to hear
CCTV to really report will be going to
the 21st of September on the 18th of
October we're really planning ahead
um the voluntary sector grants uh
cross-party members panel decision will
be noted
there will be a a proposal for Christmas
parking
in other words Christmas parking Before
Christmas as in previous years and we
will be hearing about proposals for
three new skateboard facilities
and November we will be hearing in a
report about the development of 3G
pitches
some of the other work that um the
executive are doing
um hasn't got to the point of coming to
report
councilor Arthur Williams is working
with the customer services director
Sarah Bennett on complaints handling
procedures and more particularly using
complaints to generate service
improvement
a preparation for the new Leisure
contract is going forward with
Consultants who are researching
feasibility and procurement and there
will be a member workshop being
organized by councilor Julie Gooding
councilor Michael Hoy is organizing the
budget survey and the budget workshops
which will be participated in all
members will be invited
the planning policy committee led by Jim
Cripps has undertaken a workshop to
identify opportunities on Brownfield
sites
almost finally rochford's by your side
cost of living community then is on the
30th of September taking place here
milhart Mill
Bill arts and events center uh 11 A.M to
3 P.M
we were going to have a
a member briefing on Essex Evolution on
the 11th of September that the the
government's timetable has changed and
we will now be offered on a basis of pan
Essex
um SXT Evolution briefings are being
organized and they're on the 14th and
22nd of September and member services
have been asked to communicate to all
members how they may attend
um I assume on a hybrid meeting thank
you very much
very good conservation
remember says it's noted is this report
noted
questions counselor Mr Mason I've
noticed on the key decision documents
that they're not they'll be signed off
by officers
I don't quite understand that because
surely the motion
why aren't the uh
members of the executive signing off on
there it's their portfolio like the I'm
going back on memory so I just tried to
look them up but the
um parking I think was signed off by a
on the officers and the other each one
was signed before an officer I remember
looking at thinking that's strange
I don't see why the executive aren't
taking
responsibility for it but not as much
responsibility as just making the
decision
can I just remind that with any
questions must relate to what the report
that cancellation has said
um he did mention key decisions
I did not
thanks Jim
hasn't mentioned there about the event
here for cost of living issues uh will
there be an event in the east of the
district because it's been very
difficult for the people that live in
the eastern district to get here because
of the cost of living
I don't believe almost
I'd like to refer that to other members
of the executive to answer Council Julie
Gooding in particular may wish to answer
it or counselor around Wilma Wilson I
wish there is indicated
thank you chair
um regardless I'm sorry
okay
regarding the cost of living further has
been from here at Mill Hall it's
actually one of our community
people that we work with the mega Center
are putting that on and they've hired
Mill Hall turrets around that event
um so not being rude councilor steptober
I don't feel qualified to speak on
behalf of where the mega Center puts
their events on sorry
could I ask the members of the lead team
and perhaps try and consider to see if
they can perhaps ask to make a center to
do something down the east side of the
district or something similar
contrary
thank you chairman we did have a brief
in a couple months ago from the
voluntary services and Vicky from
perhaps said that it would be
um this type of event all the way across
the district be nice to have an update
or can ask her for an update maybe she
can let us know
we're called out a hole now because we
we couldn't only really follow the
questions on Clarity so of what
councilor motion has said so I think
we're getting a little we're getting a
little bit individual but they're here
so really I'm satisfied with it so
there'll be no more questions on that so
right so um
right so members is this noted
this report noted thank you right item
16 public questions and members of notes
whether this member has already been
dealt with on an early agenda
um this is Jay away so that's it item 17
notice motions in notice there are none
and therefore this concludes the build
the business of this meeting I think
we're all attending the time now is 11
17. thank you
thank you
foreign
whilst the chairman councilor Jack
Lawman and our chief executive Jonathan
Stevenson retire from the meeting
thank you